foreign
[Music]
I'm an engineering manager at Google
leading Frameworks Solutions and
ecosystem at Cloud ml compute services
today with my amazing colleagues Alex
Damion and Carlos who have put together
an exciting session to walk you through
how to accelerate pytorch workloads
using pintouch xla
this week you have heard a lot about the
latest accelerators that are available
on gcp
in particular TPU v5e is our latest
series of tpus
which provides efficient versatile and
scalable Solutions
for ML workloads
regardless of your ml framework of
choice Cloud TPU can help you achieve
the great performance for training and
inference of your models
so whether you're using pytorch jacks or
tensorflow you have the easiest apis
available to you to train your models
today we want to show you how we can use
these TPU accelerators
to accelerate your pytorch workloads
using a key technology that enables high
performance and scale
using a distributed compiler in xl8
pytorch is able to utilize open xla as a
backend which brings incredible
performance and scalability to users
the pytosh xla project has three main
goals the first one we want to support
pie Crush community of developers with
well-tested
code examples and optimizations of
models
to enable them achieve more
second the gcp accelerator customers can
productize their pytorch workloads for
training and inference on tpus providing
great interoperability with gpus
finally ensuring that the pi torch
ecosystem is well integrated
and supported across the whole TPU
product
with pytorch 2.0 released back in March
this year pintorch introduced torch
Dynamo torch Dynamo rewrites python
bytecode in order to extract sequences
of pytorch operations into an
intermediate graph
which is then just in time compiled
using a customizable backend
one of these backends is open xla using
the open xla backend pytush operations
are converted into an establish cello
graph
statement is a portability layer between
different ml Frameworks and ml compilers
which provides backwards compatibility
of its offset
after this conversion the xla compiler
can optimize the execution at a scale
and then use the same runtime that
powers Jax and tensorflow to run your
pinecrush model
in other words using pytorch xla we have
unified the stack that powers all major
Frameworks and any optimization and
Improvement that is done in the xla
layer can be used for any ml framework
user
foreign
project
started back in 2018
with close collaboration of course with
meta
the project was announced at Defcon 2019
jointly with meta and Salesforce
in 2020 pytorch xla became generally
available with support for cloud TPU V3
pods as well as supporting uh
nitrous lightning
or the next year the team really worked
hard to make sure that we improve
usability by providing TPU VM support
and migrating to this to use the same
runtime as Jax
in 2022 we started working on Porsche
Dynamo
and this brings us to today
we are delighted to release pytorch 2.1
with integration of openxla
with this release pytorch users can use
pie crust 2.1 to run large language
models such as lama2
at very large scale on TPU v5e
and we are further investing on pushing
the boundary of a scalability with pi
torch
looking ahead we have three main
directions first interoperability
today xla Powers more than tpus
in fact using Piper xla you can run
pytosh models on many different compute
environments including gpus as well as
trainium and inferentia
second performance is the key we want to
provide the most performant solution for
all pytorch models and all pytorch users
finally we have been working closely
with our friends at meta to support the
latest apis for torch export
to enable hydroch users to run their
models at Edge
for example this enables pytorch models
to take advantage of the incredible
performance optimizations on Android
phones
Forge export is available in preview in
pytos 2.1
and I'm excited for our close
collaboration with pytorch and pytorch
foundation and with that I would like to
invite Damian sereni
to join me on the stage
[Applause]
thank you
thank you so much for uh welcoming me
here today
um so my name is Damian Serenity I'm an
engineering director at meta and I
support the pytos team within meta and I
just wanted to come up here and you know
spend a couple of minutes just saying a
few words about collaboration that we've
had we have friends with Google and
across the industry on
xla so as Shaheen mentioned right this
is not a new story we've been working
together since 2018 since the beginnings
of by George xla and that collaboration
really has grown over time
um of course since since 2018 a lot of
things have changed right so one of the
things is pytorch has grown really
substantially as a framework back in
2018 I think it was still a bit of an
upstart and now it's really grown into
[Music]
um
a leading ml framework across
you know everything from research
startups
um you know large Enterprises and of
course companies like meta that rely on
paytorch for uh for production and
throughout all that we've kind of really
had a philosophy that pytorch is really
an at hard and open source project it's
an open ecosystem and so that's why we
value these collaborations and kind of
building out in the open
so one of the exciting things that
happened last year is we decided to
actually formalize that and create a
pytos foundation which we co-founded
with Google and a number of other
companies and now has nine board members
across the entire industry for you know
working together to further the
ecosystem
and you know as um as Shaheen mentioned
we all the other thing that exciting
thing that happened last year was
releasing python 2.0 which we announced
at the conference in December and
released in March and really even the
way I think about pytos 2.0 is we want
to bring the same user experience that
people love about pytology and that's
been enabling a lot of like iteration
and research and AI which is kind of
this
very
fast-moving ego mode development
experience
and marrying that with the power of all
the exciting back ends that we've been
building along the way and including
openxla so it's really natural that that
collaboration has you know turned into
us working together on open xla and now
we're really excited to see
um what that's going to bring to the
Pietro's ecosystem and the value that's
going to bring to our users
um so of course
all of this is really about performance
right like the 2.0 story is how do we
keep pytorch the python experience and
make it performant and we're really
really excited today to see the next
generation of cloud tpus be released
with pytorch support and not like steal
the Thunder from Alex who's going to
come after me but we're seeing some
really exciting numbers around the
performance of
um play George on TPU v5e and including
our models like our next Generation open
source uh language model number two so
you'll be hearing a lot more about that
the other side of performance is scaling
right how do we scale training up to
larger and larger distributed training
and I think again you're going to hear a
lot more about that from Shaheed later
in in this talk
um so really in all of this right I the
the message I just want to convey is I
think we're really excited about all
this is happening in the open and in
partnership with Google and other
industry Partners we're super excited to
see where openxla leads
and there's a couple of directions that
I think you'll be hearing a lot more
about one is definitely the large-scale
distributor training and the other is
total export and how we can bring
kind of your pages models
um into ads and mobile devices and
that's going to be a big theme I think
coming up for uh for both of us
um so with that I just wanted to thank
Shaheen for having me and also pass it
on to Alex to Deep dive into her
performance numbers
[Applause]
thank you so much Damian I am so excited
to see the collaboration between Google
meta and our other industry Partners on
pytorch fighter Chick-fil-A under the
auspices of the pie torch Foundation
hi everyone my name is Alex spironov and
I'm a product manager for pyrochex La at
Google
now as Damian mentioned and as I heard
from so many of you during the
conference over the last few days
performance and performance per dollar
of your AI workloads is really top of
mind for many of you here and so I have
the honor and the privilege today to
share for the first time our performance
results for training and inference of
the Llama 2 model with pytorch xla on
cloud tpus and Cloud TPU v5e
llama 2 is the next generation of meta's
Open Source large language models
now I'm sure all of you in the audience
have heard about llama2 but just in case
you somehow missed all of the excitement
over the last couple of months let's
quickly cover the fundamentals
llama 2 uses an optimized Transformer
architecture and it ranges in model
sizes from 7 to 70 billion parameters
now the largest 70 billion parameter
model also uses eight-way model
parallelism
and all model sizes use sequence lengths
of up to 4096 tokens for inference
now that's a lot of numbers but the
bottom line is that llama 2 is a
state-of-the-art large language model
and it really puts AI accelerators to
the test
so how did Cloud TPU do with lava 2
training and inference well here are the
highlights
on training Cloud TPU achieved up to 52
and a half percent model flops
utilization
that is a key efficiency metric and
we're going to unpack that a lot more in
the next couple of slides
now of course after you train or fine
tune llama 2 you will want to run
inference on it and so on inference
Cloud tpus achieved up to two and a half
times greater performance per dollar
and up to 1.7 times latency speed up
compared to the previous generation
Cloud TPU V4
now just let those numbers sink in for a
moment
52 and a half percent model flops
utilization
two and a half times higher performance
per dollar
1.7 times latency speed up
those are amazing numbers
now how is this possible
well the magic comes from the combined
hardware and software optimizations
and I'm so impressed by our amazing
engineering team who makes this magic
possible
now let's take a closer look at our
numbers and our results
when it comes to training performance we
use the industry standard metric of
model flop utilization or mfu
now if you've been working with llms
you've probably heard about mfu but you
might not know exactly what it means so
let's unpack that a little bit more
we start with model flops now model
flops is the total amount of floating
Point operations that are required to
complete one forward and backward pass
during model training
now the great part about model flops is
that their hardware and implementation
independent they only depend on the
underlying model
now model flop utilization measures how
effectively the model uses the actual
underlying Hardware during training
so in our case on cloud TPU V4 on the
largest llama2 model size 70 billion
parameters
Cloud TPU V4 achieved 52 and a half
percent model flop utilization
52 and a half percent that is very
efficient
now why does it matter to you
well because you want to get the value
of your AI accelerator investment
and Cloud TPU and Partridge xla and lava
2 uses your AI compute very efficiently
and that generates tremendous value for
you for training large-scale language
models
now one of my favorite quotes comes from
Alan K one of the early pioneers of
computing who famously said that if you
care about software you should build
your own Hardware
and that's exactly what we did at Google
with Cloud TPU v5e
we designed and built TPU v5e from the
ground up to provide high performance
cost efficient training and inference
for large language models and generative
AI workloads
and because of that cloud tpb5v provides
a cost efficient scalable and versatile
inference platform
v5e achieves up to 2.5 times greater
performance per dollar on inference
v5e is also highly scalable it allows
running inference on model sizes with up
to 2 trillion parameters
and of course Cloud tpv5e provides
excellent integration with leading AI
Frameworks including of course pytorch
and we also integrate with services like
gke for orchestration and vertex AI
training and prediction services
so let's take a look at our inference
results using the latest and greatest
tpus
now when we talk about inference we use
the industry standard metric of
throughput
and to calculate throughput first we
measure a latency per token after the
model has been compiled and loaded
and then to calculate throughput we
divide the batch size by the latency
normalized over the number of chips
and so as a result throughput measures
the actual performance of the model in
production independent of the number of
chips that are used
and so on inference when serving llama 2
for the largest model size Cloud TPU v5e
achieved up to 2.5 times better
performance per dollar which we obtain
by dividing throughput over our list
price
up to 2.5 times greater performance per
dollar on cloud tpb5v compared to Cloud
TPU V4
and again you might be wondering
2.5 times that sounds pretty great but
why does that matter well it really
really matters because from talking to
many of you at the conference the metric
that really matters is how many tokens
per second how many examples per second
how many images per second can I serve
on my AI inference platform while
keeping the total cost as low as
possible
and Cloud TPU v5e was designed to
deliver exactly that
now of course in addition to Performance
per dollar we also care deeply about
latency
and latency is really important because
when we build AI applications we want
those applications to be highly
responsive to our users and to our
customers
and we're very happy to share that on
latency Cloud TPU v5e achieves up to 1.7
times speed up compared to Cloud TPU
before
so as you can see Cloud tpv5e provides a
cost-effective scalable and versatile
inference platform that delivers
excellent performance and performance
per dollar on the latest and greatest
large language models and generative AI
models including of course llama2
and now please welcome back to the stage
Shaheen who is going to share with us
the newest Innovations and capabilities
in the upcoming pyrochexole 2.1 release
[Applause]
so thank you Alex I'm really excited
about those performance results for
llama 2 on cloud tpus we are really
looking forward to the community to take
advantage of all of these capabilities
that are now packed into the 2.1 release
so the release candidate for 2.1 is
available right now the final release is
scheduled for early October
the pikish 2.1 brings a host of features
and capabilities let me walk you through
some of them
as you heard the support for cloud TPU
v5e is one of the most important things
that we are providing in cloud in
pyotech slate 2.1 release
on top of that workloads are now capable
of using an spmd API
to scale for training and inference so
this is one of the most impactful
features that I think the community is
going to love and I'll go into more
details about it later
this allows for utilization of our
multi-slice technology as well that
provides performance even when your
workload spans multiple different parts
this release also brings you the ability
to export your models and save them in
stable hlo together with tighter
integration with torch Dynamo pytotech
La users can now convert the graph
produced by pythorg xla by pytorch and
save it as an establishello model
this allows them to put this into a
serving an edge or server much easier
and finally as you saw
we have ensured that the state of the
Arts machine learning models such as
Lama 2 can really perform great using
hydrochex like 2.1
so in order to run inference
what you will do is that you will create
an xla device
in your code and then use the same torch
that compile apis that you're familiar
with and pass a parameter for open XLE
this essentially allows your pie crutch
model to use openxla as its backend
indeed training a model
is no different all you need to do is to
get the xla device and then use the same
torch.compile API with the openx layback
in parameter to train your model
this will ensure that the model is
optimized and executed using the xla
stack
you can see how easy it is to use this
incredible API from pytorch to run your
pytorch models on cloud tpus
now one of the biggest challenges of
large models are is power utilization
you want to be able to take advantage of
thousands of interconnected chips to
train a model at scale
offers several options to achieve this
there is a limit to the size of the
model that can be effectively serviced
on a single chip so to scale a model
beyond that we distribute the model over
many chips this is called Model
parallelization if you have the same
replica across multiple chips and you
Shard your data that would be data
parallelism
fully sharded data parallel or fsdp is
one way to achieve model parallelism
using pi toxla during distributed
training each device
can store a specific model Shard and all
gather the full model wastes when it is
time to perform the forward pass
we built microchick's life sap support
directly into the hugging face trainer
class so that any model using trainer
can Leverage fsdp
nested fstp wrapping is both flexible
and simple to use these new features
makes it easy to train a wide range of
hiking face model at large scale on
cloud tpus
now fstp is amazing
but there's one more thing
python Chick-fil-A introduces spmd API
the xla compiler transforms a single
device program into a partitioned one
with proper collectives based on the
user annotations and sharding
information hints that has been put in
the code
this allows developers to write pie
touch programs as if they are on a
single large device without any custom
sharding computations or Collective
Communications or complicated coding
some of the key highlights of spmd are
better developer experience
everything happens with a few sharding
annotations from the user the code is
much simpler cleaner easier to
understand
a single API that enables a large
variety of parallelism algorithms you
can do data parallelism you can do
standard uh
fstp you can do spatial partitioning and
you can combine many of these together
to achieve the best performance for your
model
second industry leading performance in
large model training
enabling pytorch and Jax developers to
take advantage of the same underlying
xla API to scale their models
this API also brings the multi-slice
technology to pytorch in fact for llama
2 training on CPU v5e
using a single CPU V5 epod or two pods
or eight pods there's only a few changes
in edits in your sharding information
finally pytos 2.1 brings a new
experimental API for torch export with
this API you can export your pytorch
model into an unstable hlo graph and
simply take it for deployment on server
or on edge
all these amazing features are available
in pytorch 2.1
and we are really excited for you guys
to try it
now if you remember we said one of our
main goals from the package x-lay
project is to ensure that the ecosystem
around Pi torch and cloud tpus is strong
and healthy and what better way to
demonstrate that
than inviting my colleague Carlos from
lightning AI to talk about actors
lightning and pytos xli
[Applause]
thank you
and thank you all of all of you for
coming in today
my name is Carlos mussoli and I'm a
research engineer at lining AI
today I'm going to talk about how you
can supercharge the process of
fine-tuning large language models using
tpus on Google Cloud thanks to Linings
open source ecosystem
first let's talk about lining lining
gives you the best tools to get started
training deep learning models using
pythons
line installs offer maximum flexibility
without sacrificing performance at scale
we designed our software with
researchers in mind allowing you to
focus on your work instead of
implementing the same boilerplate over
and over again
since it's released lining has gained
tremendous popularity it has been
downloaded almost 70 million times and
we have a strong community of over 22
000 projects using lightning with nearly
900 total contributors
now let me show you what lining brings
to the table
on the left you'll find a simple python
training script that uses python xla to
run on tpus the code is long complex
unlimited and what implements
what it implements and it doesn't even
fit on this life furthermore
it will only work on the TPU environment
requiring difficult code changes to try
out on your personal computer
on the right side you'll find a feature
complete example that achieves the same
task using python sliding our trainer
object provides total customization
and the trainer process can be extended
with the lining module a class that
offers you overridable hooks where you
can add your custom logic
with this you can fully focus on solving
your task while the trainer takes care
of Performing the training process and
model distribution
in the middle you'll find fabric our
most recent release
fabric offers seamless model
distribution while still allowing you to
Define how the model is trained it
provides expert control over your Loop
without worrying about the boilerplate
of supporting distributed environments
now that you understand the advantages
of using lining I'm thrilled to announce
that lining fully supports the newly
introduced PPU b5e architecture through
pythons xla
to demonstrate this we used legibility
is a hackable and simple implementation
of state-of-the-art Open Source large
language models
legit leverages lining fabric for
seamless mobile acceleration on tpus and
provides you with single file recipes
for text generation pre-training and
fine tuning
and here's the best part of all of this
by torch lining legibility and lining
fabric are completely open source and
accessible via GitHub
now let's talk about fine tuning llms
fine tuning is an essential process that
involves taking a pre-trained model and
adapting it to perform a specific task
by training it on task specific data
once fine-tuned these models can be
incredibly valuable tools
for various applications
we have validated TPU support by
fine-tuning llms we fine-tune both
Falcon 7 billion and Falcon 40 billion
models using the Dilemma adapter
technique
on both TPU before and the newest TPU
b5v architecture
since the models are too large to fit on
a single chip we use the python xla in
foolisher data parallel implementation
supported by lining fabric
this fstp strategy shares the
transformative blocks across the chips
in a TPU bottle
the scalability of tpus allowed us to
reach close to 50 percent model flows
utilization
with 7 million parameters and and 40
model flop utilization
with 40 billion parameters on both TPU
before and the pov5
please take a look at the graph showing
you the cost effectiveness of using the
new TPU generation compared to the
previous one with both model sizes
thanks to the improved performance per
dollar
you can find all the details or of our
benchmarks or even replace to produce
them yourself by following the link on
the right
offers bespoke implementations of its
main script
specifically designed to run on xla
this might be the largest model trained
on tpus using lining so far and now you
can easily do the same thanks to
lightning and Google Cloud
thank you
foreign